hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge I've got some potentially
funny videos here that I may or may not
laugh at but I am an iron will I'm a
locked door of emotions nothing can get
out of me no joy no laughter everything
is trapped inside workin fester and lay
low until it explodes out or I'm a
giggly [ __ ] one of the two it's either
one
I've got brand-new shirts available
they're a holographic markiplier logo
print they're available in both big and
small white and black you can go -
markiplier comm and check those out
right now try to make me laugh just try
try to try to not laugh out there if you
guys don't laugh then you have to punish
yourselves
I can't punish you exactly you got to
figure that out for your own anyway
moving on you do have to be a boy though
for the girls in a little bit that's not
funny that's not funny
I love the ingenuity but I know like
where's the
I can appreciate the ingenuity behind it
but goddamn not funny
open quite a few doors in my day so I
did what I'd always done before all
right
I took hold of the doorknob okay not
funny haven't been posting a lot lately
because I've actually trapped inside
this egg here so just hang tight guys
I'll try and pull something soon okay
that's not funny
not even clever that's not funny
why am I even close to laughing I'm not
which is the answer to that question
[Applause]
hey Josh look at this huge moth that I
found shouting it oh there it goes you
[ __ ]
isn't that cool yeah that's cool not
funny not funny not funny
this one's called how to be moth
[Music]
not funny how do I relax well like many
other Americans I come home and I I pet
my dog
you see petting the dog is one of the
most relaxing things you can possibly do
it releases a hormone called oxytocin
which reduces stress
also it lowers your heart rate and that
was so funny I don't think I laughed I
prop I might have laughed I might have
[Music]
what happened inand okay David I'm still
trying I don't know why you've been at a
bar for about three hours and you've
been shouting to your friend that you
can't hear so that is the end of the try
not to laugh challenge I unfortunately
failed some of you did but a lot of you
succeeded so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to just try a
little bit more of not laughing I'll
provide a link in the description to an
article that always makes me laugh it's
from 2010 and it's called
worst life ever the story of Kazuyuki
Fujita skull
it's an incredible read and even if you
thinking like Oh an article that can't
be that funny try it trust me
try to not laugh at this article it's in
the description and also for anybody
that won one of these shirts during the
giveaway I unfortunately can't send you
a message YouTube changed up their
system and I can't engage people unless
they're about section is set up so if
you won I have a list of every channel
that won in the giveaway
if you one go to your YouTube channel
and set up your About section then I can
send you a message for some reason
that's the only way to do it
I don't know YouTube changes a bunch of
stuff I've been talking to them all week
long trying to get this solved and they
are not helpful so if you guys can
please do that I will get that stuff to
you as soon as possible and I am backing
in the full swing of things and making
videos I'm doing videos everyday at noon
Pacific Standard Time and I'm doing some
live streams at 8 a.m. I'll also have
some gaming content here and there it's
gonna be a fun time and a lot of cool
stuff is on the way but I'm back in the
regular swing of things so if you want
to see me I'm under the live stream
tomorrow at 8 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
and videos at noon thank you everybody
so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye